today was the court-imposed deadline for
the Trump administration to reunite
families who were separated due to that
DOJ zero-tolerance approach to illegal
immigration of course all the usual
suspects in the media painted a grim
picture they are indicative of this
emotional pain and struggle that these
families who have been dealing with over
the last several weeks I met two
children from two different families one
a seven-year-old boy who loves the
superhero flash and the other an 11 year
old girl who has to help her father
operate a smartphone and likes to play
basketball they are normal kids in
almost every way normal kids dealing
with a very difficult situation tonight
the administration announced that
fourteen hundred and twelve children
have been delivered to parents in
immigration custody which took hundreds
of staffers apparently to carry out lord
knows how much money it took but the
fact that this ever happened drove the
left to cry Trump's a heartless guy a
practice that's been called heartless
and cruel by Republicans who almost
never speak out they're being held and
they're being held against their will
this is a trump policy that is blatantly
cruel host of Donald Trump's base
wouldn't tolerate seeing white children
treated like that Reverend Al
histrionics aside the White House's
hands were tied remember by that 2015
ruling by Obama judge dolly G ordering
that even children who crossed the
border with parents had to be released
from custody in 20 days well that meant
either Trump continued his fed old
policy of catch-and-release family units
caught entering our country illegally or
parents were detained separately from
their minor children because the
children had to be released the
administration chose the latter path
which led to well mostly Democrat led
protests across America which ultimately
then drove the White House back to back
down it was a total mess Congress had
the chance to change the law to close
the loopholes and let's face it they
could have tightened the asylum process
and expedited the deportation hearings
but they chose to do nada
how brave we have a broken immigration
system doesn't work for anybody least of
which is to control our border and so
when we get to the moment where we're
actually solving this problem which I
would prefer sooner rather than later I
really think it's going to gravitate
around these four pillars but then came
a typical sneak move that we expect from
Democrats but not from the president's
own party before running to the airport
today for their working August recess
the House held a sneaky voice vote on a
homeland security appropriations bill
that will only end up adding to our
problems at the border the amendment
basically codifies daca and was the
brainchild of congressman David price a
Democrat from North Carolina but wasn't
just David Price GOP congressman Kevin
Yoder who's the all-important chair of
the Homeland Security subcommittee was
also in full support of the idea
especially this part that made it easier
for illegal immigrants to claim asylum
if they credibly fear gang-related or
domestic violence Yoder claims he was
moved to change his position on asylum
due to the influence of his mother he
said today quote as a son of a social
worker I have great compassion for those
victims of domestic violence anywhere
especially as it concerns those nations
that turn a blind eye to crimes of
domestic violence well forgive me
congressman and I appreciate your
personal story but your family history
shouldn't be allowed to thwart the
president's immigration agenda and
frankly imperil the party's prospects in
the midterms until 2016 asylum was
traditionally reserved for those in fear
of persecution for things like their
religious their political or their
ethnic backgrounds not due to one's fear
of crime or the threat of domestic abuse
and his or her home it's horrible does
that is so if the new barometer for
asylum status is whether a foreigner
feels
safe and his or her home country well we
should might as well just throw the
borders wide open doesn't matter if you
have a wall or no wall because hundreds
of millions of asylum requests are gonna
come pouring in now it's worth
remembering the Center for Immigration
Studies estimates that if this house
language like that in the gang of eight
bill were to prevail in the Senate we
could be looking at thirty-two million
new voting age adults living in the
United States by the year 2036 Democrats
want desperately to replace America's
more conservative electorate with
foreign younger usually more socially
liberal voters what does that mean I
tell you one thing it means no more
Donald Trump's and big business will
revel of course in the glut of
low-skilled workers in the midst of what
they claim is a labor crunch they also
won't have to raise wages much right
which is what they're starting to do now
they're having to do it to fill these
jobs and that means more profits for
themselves but beyond all the tears the
meltdowns and a lot of sad stories some
sob stories it's critical for
Republicans not to cave to the Democrats
on immigration this is just a desperate
play by the resistance because Trump is
beating them on the economy the future
is pointing north big-time up two
hundred thirty three points right now
the markets loving this I think we're on
our way we back up maybe to those
January highs Wow when you may have five
percent GDP growth coming Friday because
they're phony Russia collusion pipe
dream is crumbling there's just not a
lot in the Trump collusion bucket to
look at and because they are incapable
of separating the president from his
base according to our new NBC news/wall
Street Journal poll eighty eight percent
of Republicans approve of the job
president Trump is doing the only
president with a higher approval rating
within their own party at this point in
their presidency was president george w
bush less than a year after 9/11 now is
not the
time for republicans to give in on
immigration enforcement or melt because
of the cheap emotional media games by
the way games that are only reserved for
non-citizens it was president Trump's
get tough approach on immigration his
relentless focus on the American worker
the American family that helped him win
the election against all odds Michigan
Wisconsin Ohio Pennsylvania giving in to
the melodrama of the moment it's not the
way to go in fact that will end up
further burdening burdening the American
taxpayer who's already fed up with a
political system that sometimes makes
them feel like second-class citizens I
know mr. president you will not let them
down
and that's the angle